every parents say American Airlines left
their children with disabilities
stranded at an airport for several hours
without proper meals or supervision the
nine kids were returning from a Virginia
summer camp when a flight delay forced
them to spend the night in a room for
unaccompanied minors CTM national
correspondent tarika Duncan is here with
more on this story
to recap parents very angry what are
they saying yes they were those parents
said that they spent upwards of hundreds
of extra dollars and special fees to
make sure their children were supervised
but they accused american airlines of
being neglectful and unprepared even
feeding the kids snacks instead of meals
[Music]
this was the happy reunion over the
weekend as nine children finally arrived
in Portland some thirteen hours later
than planned that's what we went through
was a nightmare and we should have had
to go through it the children had spent
the week at Camp new friends in Virginia
catering to kids with the genetic
disorder neurofibromatosis which causes
tumors to grow on nerves when their
layover flight was delayed in North
Carolina with mechanical problems the
kids say they sat on the tarmac for five
hours before being forced to spend the
night at the airport so I couldn't fall
asleep and when I asked him if I could
turn the light off and run company
manager they said we couldn't turn it
off and they never gave us our meds
they're gonna call security
really the parents say the airline did
not keep them updated in a statement
American Airlines says it's reaching out
to the families involved and sincerely
apologizes they say the children were
kept safe and comfortable in the care of
American Airlines personnel at all times
in a room with pillows and blankets but
the children say they had little adult
supervision few bathroom breaks and
weren't given proper meals one mother
said she got a disturbing message from
her daughter I have a text from her that
says mommy I'm so hungry
I haven't had lunch dinner or breakfast
American Airlines says it will review
what happened to the kids to understand
how it can do better next time
so just maybe the airline is upset too
any airline would be upset but it is
surprising that it would happen with so
many children yeah
17 hours to be worrying about your kids
as a parent is a really long time and to
not be more prepared I mean flight
delays happen you can't anticipate it
have something in place and these are
kids with special needs so it just makes
it even worse right